Nueva Zelanda fue uno de los primeros
lugares del mundo en dar la bienvenida
al año nuevo
con miles de personas reunidas en el
puerto de Oakland Australia hizo lo
propio Poco después con una espectacular
exhibición de fuegos artificiales sobre
el puente del puerto de sidney
los fuegos artificiales de año nuevo
regresaron a Hong Kong Después de tres
años de ausencia hace apenas dos días el
gobierno de la ciudad eliminó la
restricciones que Desde hacía tiempo
pesaban sobre las reuniones públicas
[Música]
en ujan tres años después de los
primeros informes sobre un virus que más
tarde se convertiría en Kobe 19 algunos
juerguistas se mostraban esperanzados de
cara al 2023
creo que el Coby 19 fue muy grave el año
pasado y algunos miembros de mi familia
fueron hospitalizados Espero que el año
que viene estén sanos
en Rusia Vladimir Putin aprovechó su
discurso de año nuevo para denunciar el
apoyo de occidente a Ucrania Mientras
tanto en kiev los ciudadanos usaron
salir a las calles pese al peligro
latente Hoy le di a mis hijos entradas
para el circo era un espectáculo a la
una de la tarde pero 10 minutos antes
sonó la sirena nos quedamos tres horas
en el sótano del circo
en París el mundialmente famoso arco del
triunfo se iluminó con pirotecnia
una hora más tarde Londres acogió sus
propias celebraciones con el támesis
iluminado Al filo de la medianoche
poniendo fin a un año tumultuoso en el
que el Reino Unido ha cambiado dos veces
de Primer Ministro y ha dado la
bienvenida al Trono a un nuevo monarca
Al otro lado del Atlántico el descenso
de la emblemática bola de Año Nuevo el
Times Square en Nueva York marcaba el
inicio de 2023
[Aplausos]
al sur del continente americano en
Brasil las calles de la ciudad natal del
Astro del fútbol Pelé se llenaron de
gente deseosa de festejar la bienvenida
al año nuevo y también de homenajear la
memoria del deportista que murió a los
82 años y con quien Brasil obtuvo tres
copas del mundo
[Música]